je
[Musique]
dans leur petit studio dans un coin de
montréal david et justine du groupe alfa
rococo préparent leur prochain album
il met aussi un combat pour protéger les
artistes pour les artistes je dirais et
leurs équipes ces catastrophes et
campements et vente de 10 sont en chute
libre sur spotify une écoute ça rapporte
à peu près 0,45 sous par écoute pour
l'ensemble de l'équipe donc là on parle
de du distributeur du producteur de la
maison 10 et en bout de ligne
évidemment l'artiste leur musique est
certes écouter sur plusieurs plateformes
numériques mais elle ne leur rapporte
que très peu d'argent
sachant que les gens n'ont jamais écouté
autant de musique locale qu'aujourd'hui
avec une centaine de musiciens david
bussières fondent leur groupement des
artisans de la musique
il lance une capsule en pleine campagne
électorale avec des questions pour les
candidats les gens paient pour un
appareil forfaits internet maison
forfait internet mobile et un
déboîtement aux plateformes numériques
il ya beaucoup d'argent qui est là dans
le 130 140 150 dollars par mois que les
gens paient et pikine qui s'en voit pas
voir les créateurs qui s'envoient
pauvert vers l'industrie locale culturel
je te juge
disent tout
le numérique ne fait pas non plus la
sphère des cinéastes voir le géant
netflix rafler des milliards sans payer
de taxes ou de redevances au canada
provoque la colère
on a atteint un seuil critique
réalisatrice actrice et productrice
micheline lanctôt oeuvre dans le domaine
depuis plus de trente ans on n'a jamais
eu un ministre la culture assez fort
pour nous défendre auprès du conseil
d'état
les subventions disponibles n'ont pas
été augmentés depuis 25 ans c'est pas
rester là malgré les compressions elle
parvient à réaliser ses films tant bien
que mal voulu http tapis dans une vente
aux enchères
mais il faut être plus pour beaucoup la
culture est la grande absente des débats
électoraux
pour moi le théâtre c'est encore un des
rares lieux où les êtres humains sont
réunis hubert lemire joue au théâtre
depuis une dizaine d'années une passion
qui l'habite depuis tout petit on
encourage liedholm en encouragent rester
chez soi à cliquer puis a passé des fois
ne donnera rien regardez bien juste
magazine et puis il est pressé le temps
et disparus et puis le yo facebook on
est toujours là dessus du tapis j'essaie
de comprendre pourquoi on fait la fierté
de nos gouvernements
quand on part à l'étranger avec nos
spectacles on a un savoir-faire
théâtrale avec des bouts de chandelle on
est capable de raconter des grandes
histoires
il faut qu'ils les soutiennent davantage
si on ne parle que de la démocratisation
de la culture pour le conseil des arts
le gouvernement n'en fait pas assez
comment est ce qu'on considère cette
partie de la population là alors qu'elle
a un si grand impact sur l'éducation de
nos jeunes sur notre réveil au monde
d'aujourd'hui sur notre rencontre avec
les autres et en plus de 100 d'un impact
économique
il ya quelque chose vraiment qui est à
changer et à rectifier pour ces artistes
les politiques ne sont pas adaptés à la
nouvelle réalité numérique
la solution c'est de prélever de
l'argent via l'origine de copie privée
sur l'achat d'appareils numériques
c'est de prélever aussi des montants sur
les profits que feront les france hors
d'accès internet pour mettre dans un
fonds pour aider la production de
contenu local
il faudrait s'arranger pour qu une
partie d argent qui sont perçus
par léger américain reste en production
la seule façon dont netflix peut
éventuellement profiter à la production
québécoise et canadienne c'est avec un
système de redevances comme la cftc ou
le gouvernement a forcé les
câblodistributeurs à participer
et j'aurais
requins
je prends
pour ces artistes il n'y a aucun doute
les solutions sont là et si rien de ce
fait le prix à payer sera lourd
on aura pu aller fonds nécessaires pour
générer du nouveau contenu
éventuellement on va perdre le
patrimoine de demain parce que le
patrimoine de demain c'est aujourd'hui
qu'on l'écrit donc je pense que c'est
notre culture qui est grandement menacé
quand le fait simplement le fait que les
lois et les règles ne sont pas adaptés
adapter ses lois à l'ère numérique
un combat que mènent des artistes sur
tous les fronts
[Musique]